[Music]
all right so it is time for our jeopardy
warm-up and in honor of our week-long
coverage on
pets we're going to be focusing on the
pet scene here in las vegas so
our contestants tonight susie's dad
brian loftus
ali's dad chris matthews and bentley's
papa ted florindo
all right guys you've got 15 seconds to
answer a clue and again whoever wins
tonight
gets those nice bragging rights to take
home to your pets let's get started
here is our question tonight this
clark county park ends its summer pool
season
by allowing dogs to swim
15 seconds to name this park
that goes to the dogs
love this place the dog days of summer
all right time is up ted's got this one
in the bag i've got a good feeling so
let's start with uh let's start with
brian what's the name of this clark
county
what is wetlands park no sir they do not
have a swimming pool there
but i just thought they went in the
water
like a stream upon a small light
it is a swimming pool chris you want to
take it
with brian's thought just hey there's a
big lake there sunset park
no sir that is not the county park ted
tell us the name of the desert desert
breeze
park yes tonight the dogs love it
chris we really bricked that yeah that
was an airborne
the desert breeze aquatics facility they
allow dogs on the very last day of the
summer to swim in the water
then they drain the pool i know what you
guys are thinking at home nobody else
goes back in it
denise that chris and i both chose
places with no pool
correct yeah boy correct but ted i think
has been there before so yeah
you and i went there before i met you
there remember i didn't think you
remember because it was many years ago
but that is that was a they haven't had
it in convenient
couple years they do drain the water
after the dog swim so maybe they'll have
it
this year we'll let you know